[MUSIC PLAYING]
MANU BATRA: Good
afternoon, folks.
Thank you so much for
joining us this afternoon.
What we'll be talking today is
about optimizing block storage.
Quick introductions first--
my name is Manu Batra.
I'm project manager for
GCP Persistent Disk.
With me here is Stanley Feng.
He's the engineering
manager for persistent disk,
focusing mainly on performance.
A couple of key points in what
we'll be discussing today.
[? We want ?] to cover
starting with what
is persistent disk, a quick
introduction, a quick detail
around one of the feature sets
with data management feature
set, data protection
feature set,
and getting into performance.
So the recommended
practices around how
to optimize for system
disk performance with GCP--
so we want to cover about some
recommendations around that.
And then Stanley will also be
covering a specific use case
around optimizing
MySQL performance
with a new feature that is
released in beta with 16 K
blocks.
And of course, towards the
end, we can take questions.
And afterwards, too,
we'll be hanging out,
and please reach out to
us for anything specific.
Starting with a
good introduction
around persistent disk--
with GCP, you get many options
around how you store data.
You get databases and
many kinds of databases
with in-memory relation
databases, NoSQL data
warehouses.
And on the storage side, we
have block, object, and file.
In this session, we
are mainly focusing
on block storage for GCP,
which is a persistent disk.
Persistent disk is a highly
durable, high performance block
storage for GCP.
And a couple of key facts
around block storage
is it's simple,
fast, and flexible.
The reason I say it's
simple, fast, and flexible
are around the meat of,
do we need striping?
Does it do a lot of the
stuff on the back end
versus forcing the customers
to do OS level optimizations?
It provides a
virtual SCSI device,
and it can scale from one gig
to a 64 terabyte size itself.
Getting into the block
storage ties, with GCP,
we have three different
types of block storage.
One is a local SSD.
A local SSD can go
up to 3 terabytes.
It's mainly recommended as a
high performance scratch space
because it's an
epithermal storage.
So it's local to the
VM, and it's essentially
a scratch space.
And it's priced around
$0.08 per gig per month.
Now when we get into
network-based PD,
we have two different options.
One is standard persistent
disk and SSD persistent disk.
The use cases around
them for standard
are more around large
data processing workloads
around [? dynamics ?]
processing and video editing.
And it's essentially
targeted towards a price
sensitive audience with
$0.04 per gig per month.
When we get into
SSD, that is focused
a lot on high
performance databases
like MySQL, SQL servers,
Oracle, or any other database
of choice.
It is persistent,
and it usually runs
around $0.17 per gig per month
for the SSD persistent disk.
There are some also
data management features
around it you can have.
It comes standard
with encryption.
It comes with snapshots.
So I'm going to
talk later on what
different types of
snapshots are there.
And so the scalability
functions are you can actually
have 128 PDs per VM.
And each PD can be
around 64 terabyte size.
Couple of common
patterns how we think PD
is used generally
by customers-- you
can use PD as a boot device.
You can use PD as a
boot device and use it
as a read write
volumes for your VMs.
PD also allows to
have a [? detached ?]
into multiple VMs as
a read only device.
Stanley will be covering
a couple of more use cases
around specifically how you can
use PD for data distribution
around multiple VMs.
And we also have a new feature,
which we're releasing soon,
is around synchronous
replicated PDs across zones.
So this provides
active-active applications
across two zones in the same
region in case of a PD failure.
And I'll be covering more
details in the following slides
on that front too.
But these are the
common patterns
we see around how PD is attached
to VM for different workload
optimizations.
Getting more detail into-- so
the data management features.
We covered multi-reader support.
So you can use PD in a
read only mode to share
data across multiple VMs.
PD snapshots are geo-replicated.
You can take regional and
multi-regional snapshots,
and I'll talk more
about that too.
You can scale without
interruptions.
So talking about
simplicity and flexibility,
you can actually scale a PD
without having to detach it.
You can scale it dynamically
while it's attached.
And of course, all PD comes
with automatic encryption
across the board.
Getting into more data
protection features,
PD has snapshots, and
the standard snapshots
are copied over into GCS.
So when you take a first
snapshot, it is full.
And every other snapshot
can be incremental.
Now once the PD snapshot
is taken, you can choose.
Do you want to store
them in a regional bucket
or a multi-regional bucket?
One of the features that was
asked for a long time and it
just went into production is
around PD snapshot scheduling.
With snapshot scheduling,
you can actually
control the lifecycle
of a snapshot.
How many snapshots
do you want to take?
How often do you want
to take and how long
do you retain them?
So you can define
a retention policy.
You can define a
snapshot creation policy,
and it can all work
offline without having
you to schedule with scripts or
other tools outside of the core
PD pieces.
Getting into a bit more
around snapshot location,
snapshot location is a
feature which is in beta.
And this is more for
customers who are
focused around data locality.
So if you're taking
a snapshot and you're
concerned about that my
snapshot shouldn't leave
certain localities or
you want to maintain
for either compliance or
taxation or different purposes
that corporations
have, you can actually
control precisely where
your snapshot is stored.
You can say, my snapshot
is taken from US Central
and can go to US East 1.
Or you can say, my
snapshot stays in US,
and I want to store them in
a multi-regional US bucket.
So this is truly
targeted towards where
you want to control
data locality
but still want to control--
have DR with snapshot.
Another feature which is going
GA end of the month-- it should
be in our blog post too-- is
around synchronous replication.
So PD has regional PD, which
takes two copies of a PD
in two different zones,
and all the rights
are synchronized
in the back end.
So before a write is sent
across back to the host
as acknowledged,
the write is exactly
synchronized across both sides.
This particular feature
is more targeted
towards applications
which are highly
sensitive to respond to
recovery point and recovery time
objectives.
Now getting into
performance basics,
we can look at performance in
multiple different dimensions.
One dimension that I like
to deep dive is IO density.
So when you look at IOPS, PD
standard provides 0.75 reads
and 1.5 write IOPS per gig.
And this metric is
particularly important
if you look at what's
the maximum disk
size do I need to achieve
the full IOs that I
need for my application.
Same thing for PD-SSD--
you can get up to
30 IOPS per gig.
And in the following
charts, I'll
show you kind of what's the ramp
up for PD size versus the IOPS
and megabytes per second ramp.
One of the latest changes
around PD standard
is PD standard had a bandwidth
of 80 megabits per second
for read and 120 for writes.
It just moved up to 240
reads and 240 writes.
So that should help with a
lot of throughput sensitive
applications.
For PD-SSD, we're looking
at 1.2 gigs per second reads
and 400 megabytes
per second write.
Now I talked about IO density
in terms of megabytes in IOPS.
And if you look at this
chart, you literally
can reach peak
throughput in terms
of megabits per second
for a standard PD
but by adapting a
2 terabyte drive.
Same thing for if
you are using PD-SSD
for IO sensitive applications,
you can achieve the peak with 2
terabytes also.
So that essentially
means you can actually
optimize for throughput
or IOPS depending
on what your application
needs without having
tons of spare capacity to
get to that max number.
Another criteria
when looking at what
are the different thresholds
to achieve the peak performance
is what's the size of VM that
I need to get to that peak.
Now if you look at
PD standard, you only
need four vCPUs to achieve
the max performance
on a PD standard.
And for PD-SSD, you can get
up to there with 32 vCPUs,
which is pretty aggressive in
terms of spare CPU cycles that
you would have to spend
getting to that levels,
and the slopes are--
you can get to the peak
with just 32 in PD-SSD.
I'm going to transfer
control to Stanley for more
details around performance.
STANLEY FENG: Thank you,
Manu, for the introduction.
Hello, everyone.
A brief introduction
about myself--
I work on performance
of the persistent disk
and focus on
performance of the disk
itself and also try to
optimize performance
for different kind of workloads.
So today, the first
section will be
focused around performance
recommendations, what
you can do to best utilize PD.
So let's first start with
a brief, very high level,
30,000 feet view of the
persistent disk architecture.
As you can see here,
you have GC VMs,
and you have persistent disk.
And this shows up as a
disk to the GC VMs, which
are the rectangle boxes.
And two key high level takeaways
you can have on this graph
is, one, this PD is
a virtualized disk.
It's completely virtualized.
Every copy of data-- say, for
example, look at the blue copy.
If you write a
logical copy to PD,
it's sent back down
to a massive scale
back end physical
storage system.
And it's replicated three
way or three way equivalent.
And then because it's
completely virtualized,
it does not have a
one to one mapping
from a logical processor disk to
a particular physical resource.
And it allows us to
innovate and define
some sort of unique
feature that is
unlikely to happen
in a completely
physical attached disk world.
And the other takeaway
you can have on this
is because we're built on top of
a Google internal massive scale
distributor file system,
it allows us to scale PD.
And we do a lot of
optimization for random writes.
And also in terms
of reads, we try
to read from the fastest
copy of those three.
So move on to some of
the additional details
about performance, and these
are the details that we actually
mentioned in our documentation.
But sometimes, we found
out lots of customers
often didn't pay much
attention to those.
So first, for the IOPS
and throughput limits,
when we published those limits,
in order to measure IOPS,
you use 8 kB IOs or less.
And then to measure
throughput, make
sure you use 256
kB IOs or larger
and use sequential IOs to match.
And the third point
is very interesting is
that if you attach multiple
disks of the same type
but different sizes
to the same VM,
the individual disk
can actually achieve
the same level of performance
as the sum of those disks.
For example, if you attach
one 10 gigabytes disk and then
1 terabytes disk to the same
VM, the 10 gigabyte disk
can actually perform
at the same level
as 1 terabyte plus 10 gigabyte
if you're using the 10 gigabyte
disk only.
This gives you great
flexibility in terms of IOs
and in terms of
how you use those.
As long as you buy
enough size, you
will get those IOs
regardless on which disk
you use those IOs
on for that VM.
Then this last
point, which I will
talk in great detail
in the next slide,
is about the cost of duplex.
Duplex means you can achieve the
read write limit concurrently
as a max.
So for PD-SSDs, the throughput
limit is actually duplex.
That means you can achieve the
read write limit as documented
at the same time at max.
But the rest of the other limits
like PD standard throughput
is not duplex.
IOPS limit is also duplex.
Let's take a look at the detail.
So again, this big
table and a lot of data
is actually copy pasted
from our documentation.
And throughout the
years, customers
have had questions to us and
were asking what does this mean
and what is duplex.
So I figure it's worth
calling out today
and to just give a quick
example and the introduction
of this concept.
And so full duplex means maximum
limits for read and write
can be achieved simultaneously.
If you look at the lower-right
corner of this graph,
as you can see--
this table.
As you can see, it's
very easy to understand.
For SSD read write
throughput limit,
you can achieve 240
megabytes at the same time.
If you keep hitting the disk
with maximum read and write,
both sides can reach 240.
Now what does not duplex mean?
Not duplex means
you can take a look
at the example of the
standard persistent disk read
write limits.
So if you do read
only, you can do 240.
If you do write
But what happens if you do
read or write at the same time?
Now let's assume if you
have 50% reads, 50% writes,
then proportionately,
both limits
will be reduced to the
middle, which is 120 and 120.
So that's how you can
understand read write mixed,
which is called non-duplex.
So of all these limits--
IOPS limit, throughput limits--
only the PD-SSD throughput
limit is full
duplex, so which is,
you can reach 1.2 [? G4 ?]
reads at max and 400 megabytes
for writes.
So now let's switch topic
to application level tuning
and what you can do at a high
level in your application
to make sure you can
fully utilize the disk.
So first of all,
always try to ensure
that you issue enough concurrent
IOs to reach maximum IOPS.
So the number of
concurrent IOs is sometimes
also known as queue depth.
If you use FIO frequent enough,
you will know the concept.
So always try to ensure
queue depth of at least one
for every 800 to 1,000 IOPS.
For example, if we want
to hit 12,000 IOPS,
then you want to make sure the
application can have at least
15 IOs outstanding at any time.
So if you are running
a MySQL database,
probably that means
you probably want
to configure your page cleaner
thread to be 15 or above.
So there will always be
that many IOs outstanding.
So for maximum throughput, make
sure you use 256 kB or larger
IOs and two sequentials.
For your typical
Hadoop workload,
that shouldn't be a problem.
So the next topic is about
enabling DISCARD or TRIM.
And for many of you who have a
physical world SSD experience,
you know TRIM command
or DISCARD command
is highly recommended for
physical SS device which
helps them to reduce the
write amplification effect.
And TRIM is generally also
helpful for better performance
for PD, although it's for a
completely different reasons.
But the other aspect
I want to mention here
is about TRIM actually helps you
to reduce your persistent disk
snapshot size in the sense that
if you don't enable TRIM, what
happens is when you delete a
logical fire at the file system
level, file system just changes
metadata to indicate that file
has been deleted and the fact
that those physical blocks were
still appear as
used as a PD layer.
So if you take a
snapshot on the PD,
all those deleted
files are actually
also included in your snapshot.
But if you enable
the TRIM command,
all those deleted blocks
would have been discarded,
and your snapshot size
will be much smaller.
So to enable trim,
you can do that dash
or discard option to mount.
So here are a few
things you don't
have to do to optimize
performance for PD.
One, this PD not an oven at all.
You don't have to
pre-heat it in the sense
that for example, if you
download a restore snapshot
to a new PD, after the
snapshot restoration is done,
you can just start to
read from it directly,
and it gets full performance.
And then the other
aspect Manu just
mentioned a few
moments ago is that you
don't need to read
multiple PDs to reach
the maximum performance.
Just provision a
large enough PD,
and that should give
you enough performance.
And the last one in this section
is about sharing read only data
across multiple VMs.
So you can create a PD.
You can have software packages
you want to distribute
to 10s of VMs in a zone.
And that PD will be
in a read only mode.
You can attach the PD using
this command dash dash mode RO
to a few VMs, like 10s of VMs.
And then those VMs can all
read from that PD easily.
This is suitable
for a small scale
distribution of static
content within a zone.
Now if you have a large scale,
huge scale distribution,
or if you want cross
zone distribution,
then consider using
Google Cloud Storage, GCS.
And [? all, ?] if you
have file level sharing,
especially read
write file sharing,
then we have a new product
called Google Cloud Filestore
you can use.
So then, of course, in
this particular scenario,
PD-SSD is highly
recommended here
because you can issue lots of
read IOs to this shared PD,
and SSD is more suitable
for that purpose.
OK, the last slide
applies if you
happen to use PD as a raw
device without formatting a file
system on top of it.
It's called misaligned writes.
To basically make
sure that when you do
writes to the raw
device, the write
is always aligned at the
physical block size boundary.
If you look at those 6 kB
writes that's not aligned,
the red block is the block
of the existing content
that we have to maintain.
So the way we have
to be implement it
is through a process called
read-modify-write in the sense
that we have to
read the old block
and modify it with
your new payload
for the misaligned portion
and then write it back.
This makes the write
process extremely slow.
So all right, so now let's move
on to the next section, which
is about introducing an
example of how you can optimize
a particular workload
called MySQL database using
a new feature called 16
kB physical block size
PD, which is currently in beta.
So as we optimize performance
and introducing new features
for PD, we're always
keeping in mind
that we want to do it that can
actually benefit the real world
application.
And of the real
world application,
MySQL or database application
is fairly important to many
of our customers.
And MySQL is a very common
database application.
So let's go over this
example, and let's
go over what this physical block
size, 16 kB physical block size
PD, means.
So for persistent--
what is a physical block
size, what it means in the
context of persistent disk?
So for persistent
disk, physical block
is the unit at which
writes have atomicity.
Atomicity Means you have
all or nothing semantics.
A 16 kB write, if
it's aligned, if it's
returned to a 16 kB
physical block size PD,
you will be ensured to
either write nothing--
in a failure case, a VM crash,
or your application crash,
you'll write either nothing or
write all in a successful case.
Now the default physical block
size of a persistent disk
is 4 kB, and 16 kB physical
block size has just recently
been added like probably a
month ago as a beta feature.
So then the next
question obviously
is, what do I use
a 16 kB PD for?
Then it is really designed
for your MySQL database
workload that is write heavy.
Now if you happen to run other
databases and, for example,
on SQL Server or Oracle
and those databases,
if you can change those data
page size to be 16 kB and then
use PD for-- many of those
databases have a mode to use
the block storage
as a raw device--
then you can potential to also
benefit from this 16 kB PD.
So what's the problem?
What's the problem we try
to solve at MySQL layer
with this 16 kB PD?
Here's the problem.
Here is a typical OLTP run.
For those of you who use
MySQL and manages MySQL,
the sysbench OLTP is a
standard benchmarking method
to benchmark the performance
of MySQL database.
This an eight hour run with
512 concurrent connections--
fairly heavy.
And as you can see, at the
second phase of the run,
the y-axis is the
performance DPS.
During the second
half of the run,
the performance varies greatly.
The database is, you
know, essentially not
that useful to you because the
performance varied by like 5x,
6x, and all that, right?
So now let's just do a
quick preview on what
you can achieve with a
16 kB PD and configure
the MySQL to disable that
double write feature.
And so the middle of the
graph is the performance
after using 16 kB PD.
As you can see,
it's more stable.
It's a little bit higher.
It's a bit higher than what's
the lower right corner, which
was before on the 4 kB pD.
And then this is also our
internal regression test too.
This was for the last
February and early March.
The blue lines here
are 16 kB performance,
MySQL running on 16 kB PD.
And the red lines here are
MySQL running on 4 kB PD.
And 16 kB performance is a
bit higher and more stable
than the red lines,
than the 4 kB ones.
So OK, now let's just
dig a little bit deeper.
For those of you who never
touched MySQL before,
this might be boring.
But you know, let's just
see where the problem is
and why the 16 kB PD will
help solve that problem.
The problem here is if
internally inside MySQL,
this graph plotted is
what's called a flash lag.
Flash lag means that, you
know, how much lagging behind
is the 30 page flash
versus the log file.
So here, you can
see the MySQL log
file has grown to
the ceiling, which
is 20 megabytes in this case.
And MySQL is in a
sync flash state.
In that state, MySQL will not
take new incoming mutations
unless it can find a 30
page to flash, make room
in the log file, and
then take the mutation.
This leads to the
initial problematic graph
where you see huge
variation of performance
because the database itself
is in a stop and go mode.
So in order to
control flash lag,
we want to make sure
that the 30 page
flash can be done at
a rate that's higher
than incoming write rate.
Then inside MySQL, there's an
option called a double write.
If we can disable
double write, then that
means we can reduce the 30
page flash rate by half,
essentially doubling
the IOPS you
can get on the 30
page flash front.
So then the next question will
become, what is double write,
and how does a 16 kB PD help
you disabled double write?
So double write--
InnoDB is a MySQL
storage engine.
InnoDB double write
is to basically-- when
it needs to flash 30
pages, it actually
writes that page twice in two
different locations on disk
because it needs to do that is
to guard against a torn page
situation.
A torn page situation
happens if you
write a 16 kB page on a
traditional 4 kB physical block
device.
During a failure mode,
maybe only part of the page
may be successfully written
on the disk like, say,
4 kB or 8 kB or 12 kB, right?
When that case happens,
the page is torn, is lost,
is only partially written.
You can't even replay
the transaction log
onto that page to
reconstruct a new page
because the old
page is essentially
overwritten and corrupted.
So that's why InnoDB
needs to write the--
when they flash the 30 pages,
it needs to write twice--
first time to a backup
buffer called double
write buffer, the second
page to the actual place.
If the second write
is torn and corrupted,
they can use the first
write to restore it.
Now if we can build a
16 kB atomic write path
from database all
the way to the disk,
then we can avoid the need
to do this kind of double
write because all the 16 kB
writes would have been atomic.
It will happen end to end
all the way to the disk,
have all or nothing semantics.
So that's where you
can use 16 kB PD for.
Here are the list of steps.
Here are the details.
I'm not going to
repeat those steps.
You can just Google
best practices
for 16 kB persistent
disk and MySQL,
and those steps will
show up in a document.
But one quick thing I
want to call out here
is that the ability to create
a 16 kB persistent disk
is very unique on Google Cloud.
It moves back to the
initial architecture graph
in that persistent disk is a
fully virtualized storage block
device solution built on top
of a massive distributed file
system on the back end.
Because it's fully
utilized, it's
possible that we make
these kind of features
to customize a property called
physical block size that
in the physical world would
have been of attribute
of the underlying
physical device that
is extremely hard to customize.
So here is the 16 kB PD,
and here are the steps
that you can follow to
safely disable MySQL double
write by using a 16 kB PD.
One last thing I
want to call out--
that throughout
the steps, there's
a step mentioning that
you need to use container
optimized OS which
is called CoS.
It is Google curated, and it's
supported by our Google team
here.
And it's designed for
Google Compute platform.
One thing I want to mention
here is that it is also
used by Google Cloud SQL VMs.
The reason we want to
use CoS image if you
want to use 16 kB for MySQL is
that CoS image qualification
process has built-in tests to
ensure that the Linux kernel
layers between the file
system and the disk
do not split, break, misalign
the six writes across 16 KB
boundaries.
So that is how we
ensure there is an end
to end atomic 16 kB write
path all the way to the disk.
[MUSIC PLAYING]